and there are multiple ways to define
addiction of course but in medicine when
we think about when people come to for
health care we think of addiction in
terms of the DSM term the DSM is the
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual it's
produced by the American Psychiatric
Association and in that book it has a
clear definition of what addiction is
addiction typically we think of it is
people may exhibit tolerance to a
substance they may go through withdrawal
when they don't have the substance they
may spend increasing amount of time
engaged in the behavior to obtain or use
this substance they may have had
unsuccessful number unsuccessful
attempts to cut down their use of the
substance they may use despite the fact
that they are having psychological or
physical problems these are sort of the
hallmarks of addictions so like when
people use the term in popular culture
they typically have another perspective
in mind some people use things like I'm
a shopping addict I'm a chocolate
Atika or something and that's a more
benign use of the term but then there
are other people who use the term and
they think of things like folks who will
steal your money and robbed you they're
addicts
well you can think about it from a
biological perspective what alcohol
people tend to think of folks who have a
parent for example who was an alcoholic
they may have an increased likelihood of
becoming dependent on alcohol why that's
the case we're not entirely sure but
people who are looking at genetics and
other biological modular markers but
we're not real sure but we certainly
think that they may have an increased
likelihood and then there are of course
there are important social factors doing
certain certain points of your life you
may be more likely to be addicted to a
substance because of some conditions
under which you are experienced you
don't have a job you don't have any
responsibilities you have greater access
to a particular substance than you
normally would have all of these things
could increase the likelihood of someone
becoming a